oh here's another one Eddie Lee who did
this one I don't know who's that that my
cousin oh you know I know he's your
cousin
I heard your favorite hello now did they
tell you to call no I saw you a unit you
texted me let me read the text
did we tell the audience is Eddie what
who is this we tell the audience this is
my cousin Eddie oh yeah yeah okay now
I'm reading it all right so you're
calling it now I didn't read the text
thread okay where do you live here you
still a Sacramento the second man oh I
know dude
Eddie I would anyone you know Eddie
Eddie leaves my younger one of my
younger cousins on my dad's side he's my
first cousin I grew up with him and he
is one of my favorites he's like Steve
he skateboards you he looks like he's
from data from the Goonies he mean he's
not married well you guys have that like
young data from the Goonies kind of bad
you know right still skateboard right
well you know you don't skateboard at
all now he told us in San Diego oh man
how's your wife I thought you I think I
really thought you're gonna say you know
she died
or you know the cancer got her who says
it like that yeah
Oh Steve I got I got a I got a there's
another call I got a I got a I got a
glove yeah I love you Eddie okay all
right bye
[Music]